hi Matt Welch here with my Declaration
of Independence co-author Nick Gillespie
here on ask a libertarian day the next
one comes from Penny Rosen al please
explain the libertarian stance on
education I don't understand how the
libertarian views against federally
funded education fit in with the rest of
the political philosophy how can
libertarianism or any freedom based
political system work without educated
masses I'm going to kick this one over
to the father of two public school
educated boys yeah so I went to Catholic
school for first through 12 grades and
then all of my college degrees and
graduate degrees are from publicly
supported universities so I've been in
both systems but first off I want to say
that you know it's not just federal
funding it's also state and local
funding I would rather see the state get
out of schooling altogether I don't
think you're going to get a clear
freedom oriented philosophy from people
who are dedicated to state-based views
in the first place but you can leave all
of that aside right now for the
foreseeable future and you just look at
the fact that at the K through 12 levels
since 1970 per pupil spending has
doubled outcomes have been it totally
flat regardless of the funding process
now which I would like to see shifting
to you know a much more open and
wide-ranging set of sources the fact is
is that the K through 12 system we have
now is pumping more money in for exactly
the same results that's a bad idea you
can you can bring competition and
innovation to the system through
charters through vouchers through opt
outs through homeschooling all sorts of
things that's what's happening we are at
the Berlin Wall the you know the first
[ __ ] in the Berlin wall of the school
education monopoly is happening and
that's going to bring about better
education and more thoughtful kids and
hence more thoughtful citizens getting
to the spirit of the question the
libertarian position about education is
that we are basically condemning a
generation of people into the lousy
aspossible schools and that is as urgent
a national priority and a local priority
as anything else put the money in a
backpack let the kid and the kids family
choose the school and go from there yeah
you know it's a follow up on that it's
also as somebody who benefits from other
people's tax dollars because I got two
school-age kids in public schools in
Ohio you know there's no reason that
other people should be paying against
their will or asn't as a matter of
course for my kids education that I
think is wrong we can fight that battle
we should fight that battle but first
and foremost we should fix this gigantic
multi-billion dollar system that really
sucks for the very kids who are supposed
to be benefiting from it